poi serve a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti
questo video sono pari genti siamo sul
check in che ha ovviamente questo è un
gioco molto carino c'era un altro non
vincono il nome dovevi far passare la
gente all'aeroporto che questa è la roba
molto simile giorno 1 giorno 1 siamo in
aeroporto immagino check in
dell'aeroporto
ciao ragazzi allora se riesco a fare una
roba del centro questi sono questo
giardino di fori si apre la porta
apriamo salve puccio questi tempi si
rialzi agli occhi va bene ma il seligman
38 anni avvocato deve attraversare il
confine per arrivare all'appuntamento
vediamo un po non puoi passare perché è
la mascherina non ce l'hai levati dalle
palle
salve giovanni grazie mille del kosovo
lui invece come va bisogna indossare
anche degli occhi non solo la mascherina
prova bene come sono andato via ma il
sigman incazzato nero lui 32
specializzato in malattie deve
attraversare il confine per una cena con
la famiglia va bene possiamo schedina
puoi andare
occhio agli assembramenti e salve a lei
dose hickmann quello che questo fratello
un business meeting fratello ricordati
del buon favi che ti ha fatto passare il
confine a salve lei invece a napoli j
come si chiama la coda molto belle anche
le cuffie della mascherina
vediamo devo ammazzare una persona a
deve attraversare il confine per portare
l'expo ai si riformi due casi si dice la
sua nonna va bene 24 anni studentessa
avere via fuori dalle balle sono solito
nonna a sta chiudendo per prepararmi
bene è un bel lavoro ragazzi lo farei
anch'io ci 25 minuti è finito dopo come
fare video di youtube scherzo mal
pensanti deve attraversare il confine
per andare a un party professione è
disoccupato
invece di andare ai party redditi utile
cioè manca la mascherina vai a lavorare
allora o si torna tale prodotto e
polpette michel di riso va bene 33 anni
insegnante da transare confine per lo
shopping ma ragazzi ma che ci fate voi
lo state così anche per andare a
pisciare ma scusate ho giovanna che
piacere come stai
è un coach di fitness deve attraversare
il confine per dare lezioni si può
venire il tuo paziente paziente
clientela dei match è il contrario avrei
comunque giuditta testiamo un po va bene
mascherina tutto in regola fuori dalle
balle e via prima pestiamo la
temperatura house vado a casa si riposi
è un casino
non c'è né eco vinti qua non c'è niente
non posso farlo passare né un rischio
che mi assumo io ha detto la sicurezza
il buon favi giorno 2 l'abbiamo fatto ma
tu vivi in aeroporto
ma qual è il problema suo ma la tua
nonna nota gli affetti giusti santo
iddio pacchetto non è anziana e quindi
attenzione a non far pagare deve
attraversare il confine per fare un
documentario sulla crisi della sanità
globale globale me lo sono inventato una
lacrima strappa storie vediamo un po se
puoi farlo puoi farlo vai spread the
parola e buone azioni
franco prego positivo c'è lavoro di
negativo al test di febbre crediamo non
poco il lavoro è stato fatto di merda
vai cori con ricordi che sono un casino
poi crollano i palazzi in casinò qua
appalti vai vai corri veloce e fai tuo
lavoro
morgan freeman no geremia wallace prove
38 anni ma come 32 e vissuto a chernobyl
niente febbre per il signor wallace e
allora si levi dai [ __ ]
tutto bene ci sia la volontà di farlo
apposta youtube insomma falda come
andiamo va tutto bene è una bellissima
mascherina può o forse sono genere ma
vediamo nati un porto che a mafalda come
andiamo angela pittman 73 anni campa a
caso cucina dei biscotti eccezionali ma
di persona avevo dubbi signora angela
pittman dreyer super a posto vada cucini
di biscotti meravigliosi non li compri
levi sa fare
mamma mia che più che mi scoccio a mia
nonna rialzo il momento serio del video
questa è stata la playa giornata ragazzi
po difficile ma splendida io credo che
gli lavoro sia essenziale giorno qua e
un po come phinet e freddi senza la
presenza senza freddi però che ti spunta
a destra sinistra a caso sarebbe
interessante billy cricket come fai a
chiamarti billy cricket 16 anni è
abbastanza per avere un passaporto
studente deve a 36 confine per le
lezioni private non sembra molto
eccitato di andarci da ben 16 anni
vediamo un po di cricket 6 eccitato no
ma chi se ne frega fuori dalle balle
baci della se adesso mi minimi dice
questo scommetti è visto perché la gente
è scontenta e loro respingerlo però non
posso farlo perché sono vado contro le
mie policy 33 anni delivery man deve
attrezzare confine per fare una consegna
al supermarket fratello mio no proprio
io dovrei tenere questi tre tutti tutti
e tre in alto alcune cose meli abbassano
alcune miglia alzano e lo sto facendo un
po a caso riparazioni ti dico di andare
nobili coni non andare questo qua è già
al massimo il problema è che non deve
essere al massimo secondo me c'è devo
sacrificare un po di questo per
aumentare un po di questo ho capito
quindi il sito provo lo stesso vediamo
ecco mamma mia come sia passato però se
basta tantissimo sono un sacco di soldi
però è proprio la vita da youtube
airgest deve attraversare il confine per
fare andare a fare i compiti a casa del
sud del suo amico sei gruppi di jazz
even michel deve a traccia il confine
per visitare la sua non
ammalata è un architetto vediamo badava
vada e farci attenzione i dossi st
mascherina vale infatti non ce l'avevano
perso un sacco di sanità ho sbagliato
non ci aveva la mascherina che pirla non
ci avevo fatto caso va beh speriamo che
si risentì tutto il giorno dopo giorno
se non si resetta ho perso adesso devo
sacrificare cioè non devo assolutamente
sgarrare perché la sanità style è
veramente al minimo ragazzi grazie
andiamo in borgh innanzitutto sia
infetto
peter moore o deve attraversare il
confine per dar da mangiare alle sue
scimmie no don payne
si no caw kat adesso tutto al minimo
quindi devo sacrificare una delle due
cose
ti prego ai la mascherina ti prego non
essere infetto ti prego della traversata
e confine prevede la sua fidanzata vai
vai vai tromba pure su arm cortex
meno male che mi hai alzato i punti
perché stiamo veramente nella cacca
piena to perfetto non è la mascherina
però deve attraversare il confine per
soddisfare vabbè non me ne frega niente
ho fatto aperto un po di felicità o un
po di sanità sono tutte uguali
io perdere un po di felicità quindi non
ti mando dato tossini pure fai schifo
il coso al minimo però ho finito quindi
chi se ne frega bene è il giorno 7
spesso sia più difficile
ciao tutto al minimo non posso fare più
niente
[Musica]
dimostrazione a tutto il mondo il comite
fuori controllo ma cosa
game over play again mannaggia il
cacchio perché è scesa al minimo la roba
di felicità ma cosa vuol dire se c'è
comiti non ti mando a in messico a per
la quale ragazzi questa sera a check in
bellissimo secondo me ma mi sia piaciuto
ragazzi questo momento non mi piace
anche ministro sacconi ad andare
iscrizione per ultimo iscritti come
sempre scriviamo ad un prossimo video è
la ragazza
[Musica]
no